we've announced the non-domestic support
package which means that the wholesale
price electricity will be 211 pounds per
megawatt and for gas will be 75 pounds
per megawatt and from that customers
will then get their prices so it is
providing for the non-domestic market
which includes schools and hospitals
Charities and businesses something that
is equivalent to the support for the
domestic sector it's more complicated
because there isn't a price cap for the
non-domestic sector but it will have an
equivalent effect and it's a huge
support for business to ensure that they
can cope with the rise in the price of
energy that's come essentially from
Putin's War cost any information on cost
but the difficulty with giving you a
cost figure is that this will depend on
where the price of energy goes over the
winter and that's very difficult to
forecast so I can't give you an absolute
cost but we are talking about many
billions of pounds tens of billions well
it will be into tens of billions
unquestionably one of the questions that
business has asked today is why the
business support package non-consumer
package lasts for six months whereas the
consumer package lasts for two years can
you just give us a bit of indication
you're thinking is that because you
expect gas prices to go down after six
months or is that a question of course
or why is that it's because it's a much
more complicated Market with a whole
variety of contractual Arrangements what
we needed now immediately quickly was
something simple that would give people
confidence through the winter
what we will have is a review in three
months time which will allow us to see
that we are giving support in the right
places and that we can ensure that
continued support
um if that's necessary it is directed at
where it needs to go so it's essentially
recognizing that there is an urgent
problem now that needs a big package a
broad scheme but because people have
Hedges and long-term contracts it will
be possible to Fuller analysis of the
market to understand where support is
most needed during the six-month period
um because companies lead a bit of
stability in order to plan in order to
invest which is what you want them to do
um they are wondering what's going to
happen after six months can you give any
indication of how you will determine who
should get help after that six months
free for example takes one example
um if gas prices are as high as they are
today could a school expect support in a
year's time well most schools are funded
via the taxpayer anyway
so they receive money from central
government the state system but we are
obviously going to have their own
buildings we are going to have to
support and that's what we're announcing
today the state sector as well as the
private sector this is a fundamental
increase in costs across the economy and
schools and hospitals and Care Homes are
obviously going to be able to need to
afford their energy in a year's time as
well as today I can't announce future
schemes
um it would be wrong to do so and we
need to make sure that we use this time
to find out where the support is needed
um
but can businesses and public sector
bodies afford the level of increase that
there has been well by and large no and
that's why this scheme is being
announced now all of this paid for by
borrowing at the point where the cost of
borrowing is the highest into the early
1980s and today is an open-ending fairly
open-ended sound of a commitment going
on you know at a cost of tens of
billions going on indefinitely no
interest rates aren't as high as they
were in the early 1980s the amount that
we are spending on our borrowing is the
highest but the issue with that is a lot
of that is in relation to index linked
guilds and actually the cost of index
link guilds will be lowered because this
intervention will lower the rate of
inflation so there is a a benefit in
terms of the guild Market through this
intervention
um but this is a burden that would fall
on the economy one way or another and
the question is should it fall on
individuals non-business is who simply
cannot afford it or is it something that
has to be born collectively on a balance
sheet that can bear it and it seems to
me it's obvious that it has to fall on
the balance sheet that can bear it but
you're quite right to point out that
this this has a cost Northern Ireland
um when the original announcement was
made because of the Northern Ireland
protocol uh you're unable to say what
exactly was going to happen there what
can you say today I can say that
Northern Ireland will have an equivalent
scheme for gas and electricity and there
is a scheme also for heating oil because
two-thirds of households in Northern
Ireland are dependent upon heating oil
Northern Ireland also requires
legislation which will be introduced
along with the legislation to cover the
non-domestic side and some additions to
the domestic side domestic side didn't
of itself need legislation but as we are
legislating there will be an element of
that because Northern Ireland didn't
have a price cap and has a different
regulator so it's therefore been an
equivalent solution rather than the same
solution as GB as having nobody in
Northern Ireland will pay more than
anybody on the GB maintenance the the
scheme will be equivalent and we're very
conscious that there's more use not just
actually if using oil but also of coal
and of bottled gas